To give a complete algorithm,
for coarsening a graph,
you need a scheme to decide
which vertices to combine.
One idea is to compute a matching.
So what's that?
Here's a formal definition, a matching
of a graph is a subset of edges,
such that,
no two edges have a common end point.
It's, basically, an independent set,
but for edges, as opposed to vertices.
For instance,
take these three highlighted edges.
They form a matching because
they don't share any end points.
That is, suppose you wanted to add this
edge to the matching, bad OMSCS student.
You can't add this edge because it would
touch an existing edge of the matching.
So that's a matching.
What's a maximal matching?
A maximal matching is one to which
you can't add anymore edges.
In fact, this matching is maximal.
In fact, if you go through all
the remaining unmatched edges,
you'll find that you can't add any
of them to the current matching.
I want to contrast maximal to maximum.
A maximum matching is the largest
matching, for example, this
graph has at least one more matching,
with more than three edges in it.
Can you find it?
Here's one, though there might be more.
Okay, back to maximal matchings.
Maximal matchings are easier to compute,
so we'll focus on those.
Indeed, this is a good time to check
that you understand the concept of
a maximal matching.